النار تمطر على مدى عقود والناس استوعبتهم
الان علينا ان نتحول الى التنفيذ علينا ان
نتحول الى وضع مبادرات
للتعامل مع المشكله
[موسيقى]
مين عندك هناك مطالبات بعدم الاعتماد على
البترول والفحم
وبعد ما صارت الازمه في اوكرانيا صار في
مطالبات برفع انتاج الفحم والبترول هذه
هذه
المواقف المتناقضه
اساسها
الحوار الذي ليس مبني على منطق وعلى امور
[موسيقى]
على سبيل المثال الدول الاوروبيه تفرض
ضرائب 200 في الميه على البترول واحد
الحجج انه المناخ في نفس الوقت يقدمون
مساعدات للفحم الذي اسوا للمناخ من
البترول
[موسيقى]
الحفوري سوائل البترول او الفحم حيستمر مع
العالم على مدى عقود
التغيير
للطاقه في العالم وما نستطيع ان نلبي هذه
الحاجه الا اذا وجدنا
مصادر الطاقه
[موسيقى]
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لدينا اكثر من
60 مبادره في الداخل كما ذكر
ولدينا مبادرات بالنسبه للسعوديه الخضراء
والشرق الاوسط الاخضر
الجهود وتكثيف الجهود من اجل تخفيف
الكربون ومن اجل الرفع
المستوى الاكسجين